according then to the law of this
inverted world what is like in the first
world is unlike to itself and what is
unlike in the first world is equally
unlike to itself or it becomes like
itself expressed indeterminate moments
this means that what in the law the
first world is sweet
then this inverted in itself is sour
what in the former is black is in the
other white what in the law of the first
is the North Pole of the magnet isn't
its other supersensible in itself that
is in the earth the South Pole but what
is their South Pole is your North Pole
similarly what is in the first law what
in the first law is the oxygen pole of
electricity becomes in its other
supersensible
essence hydrogen pole and conversely
what is there in the hydrogen pole
becomes here the oxygen pole in another
sphere revenge on an enemy is according
to the immediate law the supreme
satisfaction of the injured
individuality this law however which
bends me confronts him as himself a
person who does not treat me as such and
in fact bends me to destroy him as a
individuality this law is turned round
by the principle of the other world into
its opposite the reinstatement of myself
as a person through the destruction of
the alien individuality is turned into
self-destruction
if now this inversion which finds
expression in the punishment of crime is
made into a law it to again is only the
law of one world which is confronted by
an inverted supersensible world where
what is despised in the former is
honored and what in the former is
honored meets with contempt the
punishment which under the law of the
first world disgraces and destroys a man
is transformed in its inverted world
into the pardon which preserves his
essential being and brings him to honor
section 157 introduced us to this notion
of the inverted world as a second super
sensible world now we're actually going
to start exploring this inverted world
in relation to the other worlds that
we've talked about before we start going
into this though I want to remind us of
something that we saw a little bit
earlier back in distinguishing these
worlds from each other
Hegel is not saying that there are
radically distinct worlds out there sort
of like private little universes or
separate domains where there would be a
super sensible world over here and the
sensible world over here they
interpenetrate each other as we've seen
as a matter of fact in a way the term
world is not the best way to talk about
it but we have to struggle here because
the very notion of world or universe or
the the domain of what is means that
we're going to have to somehow integrate
these to each other so when he giggle is
talking about that you want to keep all
of this in mind that we saw in earlier
paragraphs dealing with the relationship
between the world of appearance or the
sensible world and the super sensible
world of laws that seemed to be an urge
you know the world of changers the world
of the the static eternal all of this is
going to apply equally to this
conception of the inverted world so he
talks about there being a law of the
inverted world and I gotta remind
ourselves when we're talking about law
we're not worried so much about a
lawgiver in that respect we're thinking
about some form of intelligibility that
encompasses and makes sense out of
things that determines them that we're
able to grasp with our understanding and
so he says you know what is this law and
while it says what is like in the first
world or in the world it is unlike to
itself
okay dialectical progress that we've
seen already
for here we're going to see what we call
determinate negation going on and if
you've forgotten what a determinate
negation is you want to go back again to
the preface and look where Hegel is
working that up much of what he was
doing in the preface you know in sort of
the abstract we see him doing in the
specific as he's going through the
phenomenology so if what is like in the
first world is unlike to itself can we
apply the same logic to the unlike what
is unlike in the first world it is also
unlike so there's like a second type of
unlike Ness but that turns it into being
like to itself so there's this
bipolarity that's going back and forth
that's part of the law of the inverted
world people is going to use four main
examples over and over again throughout
this section we could pick all sorts of
other ones if we wanted and we're gonna
see there are other examples like this
about a punishment or crime or
aggression or however we want to put it
that could apply just as well so he says
expressed indeterminate moments here's
the examples that he wants again this
means that what is in what in the law
the first world is sweet in this
inverted world is sour okay so we've got
one relation there what in the law of
the first world notice what he's saying
there he's not saying what is in the
first world sweet is simply by virtue of
this law sour so the law of the inverted
world isn't like a machine where you
just you know put stuff in and crank it
and you know whatever you put in comes
out it's opposite it's not like kids
saying okay now it's opposite day but
it's not opposite day it's not a
decision procedure it's not an algorithm
we're talking about Laura's here so
we're talking about you might say
systems systems in which things are
connected with each other so what is
sweet being sweet is is a whole bunch of
relations right it's not just an
immediate boom there it is in your mouth
or in your your taste buds there's a lot
of stuff going on there
what in that system is sweet is in the
inverted world also sour does that mean
that it's no longer sweet well we're
gonna see as we go on further with this
what is black he says here we go what in
the what in the former is black is in
the other white again what is black in a
law is white in another law in a war
which in a certain way interacts with
the original block what corresponds to
the North Pole when we're talking about
magnetism right is in the inverted law
the South Pole
he's also got these examples that I
think you know when he's talking about
electricity what he has in mind here are
something like the terminals on a
battery and if you think about what the
terminals on a battery represent there
is positive and negative charges which
are coming from ions or some other you
know source I suppose if if you have
another way of doing it
think about static electricity or stuff
like that and you know they're switching
positions so when he's talking about the
oxygen what he means there I think is
the negative Pole somebody might correct
me if I'm wrong the hydrogen the Zaire
Pole this is actually the monster pool
in German the sour Pole is the hydrogen
Pole and that is positive
these are fluctuating back and forth so
what does it sound like it sounds sort
of like I use the word you know before
bizarro world or you know you might
think about if this works for you better
opposite day you know you get all sorts
of conundrums as soon as we ask somebody
is it opposite in them they say no well
if it's not opposite day than it is
opposite day you have this entire logic
going on there one of the problems that
you see the reason why I use this term
bizarro world
bizarro was this antithesis you might
say to Superman and I don't really know
the origins story because I
really got in the DC Comics but you know
you think about it this way you know
where Superman has like a normal face
bizarro has this weird almost Picasso
like face
bizarro lives according to the rules of
ops the world so if he says I hate you
he means I love you now can't a world
like that really be adequately
conceptualized you know fully worked-out
there's there's sort of an internal
contradictions that are going to arise
so it's not something that can be
entirely coherent so what he's talking
about is the law the inverted world is
not generating another world that is
like just simply totally opposite
another great example there was a show
that I used to love as a kid called
tales from the darkside and that's
probably a little bit closer to what
Hegel is talking about here and hails
from the dark side it wasn't completely
opposite to our own it was rather that
there's a world behind the appearances
that we you know pay attention to in the
the brightly lit world of our experience
and it's a world that's more dimly lit a
dark side underneath everything Hegel is
saying there's something along those
lines now it gets a lot more interesting
when we get to human examples I mean
humans taste sweet and sour register
black and white all that sort of stuff
and I suppose you know there is
electricity in nature but there's no
batteries in nature without us doing
that sort of thing so he says in another
sphere revenge on an enemy is according
to the immediate law the supreme
satisfaction of the injured
individuality so we're talking about a
human example here later on towards the
end he's going to talk in terms of a
polarity between contempt and honor what
is content held in contempt is now
treated as being honored
what is honored is now treated as as you
know lesser as something that's
dishonorable as worthy of contempt so
let's look at this example this is going
to lead us into some some interesting
speculations in the immediate
law in the first world revenge upon an
enemy is the supreme satisfaction he
says of injured individuality so what
he's what he's discussing here is what
it means not just to be a human being as
part of a species part of a culture but
to be an individuality when we think
about the way a revenge or honor or
anger or aggression work they don't
happen just on the basis of this nation
against that nation it happens on the
basis of individuality as well revenge
is something that a person takes enough
upon another person who has injured them
who has wronged them and now if we
unpack this dynamic we're gonna see
what's actually involved in here so it
involves confronting the enemy or the
criminal as he's going to talk about
later as an individual in order for me
to take revenge I have to single out the
person that I'm taking revenge upon and
you know distinguish them from other
individuality and distinguish them from
myself I can only do that if I do in
fact in some way treat them as an
individuality but why am i treating them
as an individuality so that in the next
move I can then crush them I can take my
my revenge what am i doing that I'm
doing that because that individual does
not treat me as an individual does not
treat me as having any sort of inherent
dignity does now treat me as somebody
who is worthy of what Hegel is going to
call later on recognition so there's a
lot going on here isn't there he says in
in the the immediate law the supreme
satisfaction bids me to confront him as
himself a person who does not treat me
as such in fact bids me to destroy him
as an individuality so we've got here it
is sort of a tit for tat right you
didn't treat me as an individual I'm not
gonna treat you as an individual
you hurt me I'm gonna destroy you but in
all of that you have to be treating the
person as an individual in order to not
treat them as an individual it's again
subject to the logic of this and we see
a transformation taking place here
through determinate negation as the
inversion becomes evident so what is the
inverted law say he says the
reinstatement of myself of a person
through the destruction of the alien
individuality has turned into
self-destruction now what does that mean
it means that we're taking a bigger view
on it if I soul thoroughly we're gonna
see this come up at the master-slave
dialectic destroy another person there's
no way I can get recognition from them
I can only get recognition from the
other people who watch me destroy this
person you know as bystanders but I
can't get it from them directly what is
it that a person who has really been
wronged wants from the other person they
want that other person to somehow Mason
is right the injury by saying oh I was
wrong I beg your pardon and we're gonna
see him address that this is the
inverted law this is something that is
going beyond and yet is existing in the
same realm as the immediate law these
are both possibilities they you might
say inhabit the same space of the will
the same space of human possibility and
you can't simply compel somebody to
transform their the punishment that they
desire to inflate into pardon for the
other person they have to actually
decide to do that or it's not really
pardon you're just you know coercing
them and not treating them as an
individual themselves this is why you
know when you tell you know people yeah
I forgive so-and-so so you have to
forgive so-and-so too you know he would
say that's nonsense
that's actually not treating people as
individuals it's hate
so he goes on and he says here we go if
now this inversion which finds
expression of the punishment of crime is
made into a law it too is again the law
only the law of one world which is
confronted by an inverted supersensible
world where what was despised in the
former is honored and what in the former
is honored meets with contempt there's a
an inversion that goes on why because
within the very immediate law because of
the Hegelian dialectic there is this
capacity for self uttering fur for
casting something else outside of itself
that says wait a second there's more to
the picture than originally met the eye
let me tell you about pardoning or let
me tell you about the the play of
individuality so when you take a
position in something very concrete like
this you are taking it as if it is the
be-all and end-all and then you find out
there's more to the story
that's what Hegel's talking about here
so he says the punishment which under
the law the first world disgraces and
destroys a man that's the purpose of
punishment in the first world to wipe
out the crime to set things right is
transformed into the pardon which
preserves his essential being and brings
him to honor so we have a very
interesting development taking place
here which is going to receive further
discussion in the other paragraphs
looked at superficially this inverted
world is the opposite of the first in
the sense that it has the latter outside
of it and repels that world from itself
as an inverted actual world that the one
is appearance but the other the in
itself that the one in the is the world
as it is for another whereas the other
is the world as it is for itself so that
to use the previous examples what taste
sweet is really or inwardly in the
things sour or what is North Pole in the
actual magnet in the world of appearance
would be South Pole in the inner or
essential being what presents itself as
oxygen Pole and the phenomenon of
electricity would be hydrogen pole in
the unmanifested electricity or in
action which in the world of appearance
is a crime would in the inner world be
capable of being really good a bad
action may be well intentioned
punishment is punishment only in the
world of appearance in itself or in
another world it may be a benefit for
the criminal but such antitheses of
inner and outer of appearance and the
supersensible
as of two different kinds of actuality
we no longer find here the repelled
differences are not shared of fresh
between two substances such as would
support them and lend them a separate
subsistence this would result in the
understanding withdrawing from the inner
world and relapsing into its previous
position the one side or substance would
be the world of perception again in
which one of the two laws would be
operative and confronting it would be an
inner world just such a sense world as
the first but in the imagination it
could not be exhibited as a sense world
could not be seen heard or tasted and
yet it would be thought of as such a
sense world but in fact if the one
positive world is a perceived world and
it's in itself as its inversion as
equally thought of as sensuous then
sourness would would which would be the
in itself of the sweet thing is actually
a thing just as much as the latter that
is a sour thing black which would be the
in itself of white is an actual black
the North Pole which is the in itself of
the South Pole is the North Pole
actually present in the same
the oxygen pool which is the in itself
of the hydrogen pool is actually present
in the same voltaic pile the actual
crime however has its inversion and it's
in itself as possibility and the
intention as such but not in a good
intention from the truth of intention is
only the act itself but the crime as
regards its content has its reflection
into self or its inversion in the actual
punishment this is the reconciliation of
the law with the actuality opposed to it
in the crime finally the actual
punishment has its inverted actuality
present it in such a way that the
punishment is an actualization of the
law whereby the activity exercised by
the laws punishment suspends itself and
from being active the law becomes again
quiescent and is vindicated and the
conflict of individuality with it and of
it with individuality is extinguished
a lot going on in section 159 I'm not
going to try to put all of it on the
board
I've just got sort of the main structure
of what we want to talk about here on
the board without the the examples that
we're going to examine in the course of
this so he says looked at superficially
remember that that there is a
possibility of going astray with all
this talk of worlds right so looked at
superficially this inverter world is the
opposite of the first in the sense that
it has the latter outside of that right
it's a separate worlds like what I've
got here the first world casts the
inverted world outside of itself as you
know other to it the inverted world that
repels the first world we've got two
different worlds here so he says his the
lander outside of it repels that world
from itself as an inverted actual world
so to actual worlds this first world the
inverted world
Superman's world or our world bizarro
world right the look well-lit area down
the dark side
all of these presume that what we're
talking about as Hegel is gonna show us
is that we have two separate realities
each of which is real each of which is
substantial that's not going to be the
case as we pointed out so he goes on and
he says this one is appearance that one
as the in itself we've already been
there right the super sensuous world as
opposed to the world of appearance this
one as for another we've already gone
through that with the dialectic of force
this one as it is for itself so we get
you know nice contrast there if we stuck
with that we would have something like
you know konchem ism or perhaps a human
viewpoint on things or who knows we know
what sort of metaphysics Hegel isn't
going to have that sort of view but
let's go through the examples so he says
to use the previous examples what tastes
sweet in the first world is really or
inwardly in the things sour so sweetness
wouldn't really be sweetness it would
really be sourness and sourness
correspondingly would be sweetness right
because
this is the in itself is just the world
of appearance
what is North pulling the actual magnet
in the world Minh the world of
appearance would be South Pole in the
inner or essential being and we can go
on and on the oxygen pull the hydrogen
pole and then we get to this or in
action which in the world of appearance
is a crime so an action against a person
an action that violates a moral law
would in the inner world be capable of
being really good why a bad action could
have a good intention right and really
it's it's not so much the action itself
that is of concern here it's the
intention of the person that really
matters this is a position that Hagel is
going to you know slam him down on time
after time after time through the rest
of this work when he's talking about
morality the actual action that has
effects within the world is in fact
important and merely having a good
intention doesn't you know negate that
so he says another one thought
punishment is punishment only in the
world of appearance in itself or in
another world and may actually be a
benefit for the criminal and in fact it
could be a benefit from the curb for the
criminal but that's not going to really
work this is the sort of viewpoint that
we've already looked at before as Hegel
says the understanding if it took this
stance on things would slide back into a
previous position the dialectic doesn't
just you know keep generating the same
old stuff over and over and over again
it wants to make some progress so where
do we go from here
he says these antitheses of inner and
outer appearance of the supersensible is
of two different kinds of actuality we
no longer find here they're not two
different kinds of actuality the
repelled differences are not shared of
fresh between two substances and would
support them and lend them a separate
subsistence we don't have two different
worlds that could exist independently of
each other and I'm just sort of
fortuitously connected up together by
taking in a whatever's hot low here and
hi there and vice versa sort of key a
stick structure like I said before these
have two interpenetrate and be
integrated with each other and doing
that is going to take some work so he
says these are the one side or substance
would be the world of perception again
in which one of the two lives would be
operative confronting it would be an
inner world just such a sense world as
the first but in the imagination it
could not be exhibited as a sense well
and here we're getting a really
interesting insight this is something I
want to dwell on a little bit because
what we're doing here is foreshadowing
something that's very important the term
that's being translated in the Miller
translation
it has imagination for Stella it is also
one that's going to be used for
representation another term that gets
used sometimes is picture thinking Hegel
will contrast this against the McGriff
or potentially gonna tank it you know
conceptual thinking no notional thinking
when we're relying upon the mere fact
that we can in fact come up with an
articulation for something that doesn't
mean that that is actual or that is true
we can often be misled here's a great
example wooden iron you know this is one
of heidegger's famous example or square
circle that's something that you can
come up with a linguistic expression for
and it can't really exist if you think
it out it doesn't really work does it
but that's where understanding or going
beyond that reason is something
different than just mere imagination we
can imagine an inverted world but we
can't really follow it all the way
through you remember I said bizarro
world if you completely think it through
or the opposite you know david game if
you completely think it through it
starts to collapse in on itself
that's what Hegel is getting at here so
he says the imagination it could not be
exhibited as
since world could not be seen hurt or
tasted yet it would be thought of as
such a sense world but if in fact if the
one positive world is a perceived world
and it's in itself is equally thought of
sensuous then sourness which would be
the in itself of the sweet thing is
actually just a thing as much as the
latter a sour thing right we have a
whole range of things it wouldn't be the
same thing which is both sweet and sour
it would be there's a sweet thing here
that corresponds to a sour thing over
here sour thing which by the way we
can't taste because it's in the in
itself the world beyond appearances
right that's not gonna work this this
whole picture that we've got drawn here
cannot be the case why is Hegel telling
us about this because he wants us to see
that this cannot be the case so that we
can move beyond that so he goes on and
he says if we think about a crime in
this example it would have its inversion
and it's in itself as possibility so
crime interestingly enough shows us that
this isn't going to quite work there's
no being over here in the world of the
in itself that can correspond to the
being over here or the event over here
in the world of appearance why not well
we have the active crime we have the
actuality of one individuality acting
against or negating another
individuality and then over here we have
what the possibility which is intention
not intention as a good intention he
says but intention as such the truth of
intention is only the act itself which
is over here right so we have intention
nobody have act over here intention
refers to the act this cannot be a
substance the intention can be in a
substance so can the act but it has to
be the same so
or you know we have to you know say
we're acting upon a substance or
something along those lines so he says
the crime as regards its it's a it's in
itself as possibility is you know this
intention the crime has regards its
content has its reflection in to self or
its inversion in the actual punishment
where does the actual punishment happen
not over here over here as another act
by the person who or the somebody
standing in place for the person like
the government does when they punish who
is inflicting something upon that person
the world of appearances right we don't
take away people's intentions we take
away their capacity to actually act we
throw them in prison or we impose some
sort of penalty upon them so he says
this is the reconciliation of the law
with the actuality of Coster to the
crime finally the actual punishment has
its inverted actuality present in it in
such a way that the punishment is an
actualization of the law here's here's
where he's getting to something really
interesting if we consider punishment
and angle could have picked all sorts of
other examples of human activities like
trading or you know law or stuff like
that things that you will talk about
later on but he's talking about
punishment here when a punishment
actually occurs it ends up negating
itself because what it does by setting
things right is undoes the wrongness in
a certain way it's determinate negation
right wrongness takes place you're going
to inflict some sort of evil upon some
person and then it's transmuted somehow
you negate the negation and you get a
positivity of reconciliation of
retribution of justice however we want
to put it so he says here the activity
exercised by the law as punishment
suspends itself it takes itself out of
commission by virtue of being that thing
it's got that self other end going on
and is the law becomes again quiescent
and is vindicated right when somebody is
for the crimes that they're committing
let's assume everything's going right
here right the law then becomes sort of
inert it doesn't have to do anything
more than that things have become
vindicated harmony has been restored the
conflict of individuality with it and of
it with individuality ends up being
extinguished what would conflict of
individuality people don't like being
punished the person who actually acts
against another person usually doesn't
want to bear the the brunt of the
punishment that's being inflicted upon
them but once it's been imposed and you
know things have been brought back to
where they need to be that's all right
so where are we left after this this
isn't the model that we're going to use
rather these are going to end up you
know sort of fusing into each other